- j'ai piscine couverte à l'eau chauffée
une âme givré les sa frilosité au
vestiaire pour plonger dans un lac 9
degrés elle est là juste température
maintenant
un peu plus froid ça aurait été mieux
mais
à seulement 18 ans noemi payen le feu
sacré une ambition débordante avec des
stations d'entraînement au quotidien
toujours à basse température c'est
surtout pour s'habituer à la température
après c'est le jour j où il faut y aller
tout de suite à 4° faut pas réfléchir
4 degrés au thermomètre une température
imposé fin janvier en haute savoie lors
du championnat de france de glace et sur
trois jours de compétition des centaines
de nageurs vont participer à 14 courses
ou brasse ou papillons des épreuves bien
connu en individuel ou en relais sur 1
km pour les plus téméraires un programme
qui impose aux participants une
préparation de tous les instants
c'est trop
la pratique de la natation une activité
aquatique exercer en famille
commencée il ya 12 ans et 12 ans et que
mon voisin faf et puis prône le continue
je te re continue au début j'ai suivi
pour apprendre à nager et après avec
l'ambiance et j'ai aimé l'accroché à ce
sport du coup j'ai continué de
compétition ensemble voilà est-ce que
vous êtes dit quoi vous a annoncé ça
comme ça tu prends comme un juge en
passant par la france donc là c'est
juste dit qu'il était complètement folle
c'est impossible ça lui ressemble oui
c'est totalement quand j'arrive temps
mais on a réussi pour le libre il ya
beaucoup de nageurs maintenant qu'on
suivait pour le goût c'est plutôt cool
d'ailleurs parce que c'est pareil c'est
une discipline qui la prend de l'essor
voilà aussi voilà donc mais non mais
l'eau glacée
700 euros et des contrats de sponsoring
à nos élus baillant pour voir son
ambition raisonnée en haute savoie loin
des bassins de son cher matériel